my name is emily grangine i'll be
talking with you all today about my
thesis project bodies land and instagram
network forging and infrastructural
media in the us
and for anyone who's not familiar with
foraging
in the us generally it's understood as
the practice of collecting foods
medicines and other resources from the
environment
i'll begin by explaining what network
foraging is and why it's topic worth
investigating
then after that i'll discuss my research
question
and what the central claims of my thesis
are
then i'll talk about who i am as a
researcher and how this project relates
to my background
i'll then describe the theoretical
approach and methods i used as well as
some of my key findings and implications
and i'll end with a brief summary of my
talk as well as acknowledgments of the
many people who've supported this work
so what is network foraging
i am using this term to refer to the use
of social media to learn about the
environment practice foraging and share
foraging knowledge and experiences with
others
alexis nicole nelson pictured here who
often uses the handle black forager is a
prominent networked forager who rose to
fame in spring 2020 after she started to
post these very playful colorful sort of
instructive videos demonstrating how to
forage in her neighborhood in columbus
ohio
my use of the term networked is inspired
by zainab tuffeki's use of the term in
her book from 2017 called twitter and
tear gas which examines networked
protest movements that rely on digital
technologies like twitter
although there's been a lot of academic
work that
examines the use effects and
infrastructures of social media
platforms and then other academic work
that examines foraging practices around
the world and through history
very few scholars have approached
questions around the way in which people
are using social media or digital media
to forage
so why does networked foraging matter
what makes it a useful topic to study
first of all when you look at the
history of foraging in the us it's clear
that it's been a deeply political issue
since the country's founding
starting with the settlement of european
colonists and displacement of indigenous
peoples from their ancestral homelands
the right to access and forage on a
particular area of land in the u.s is a
privilege not to take for granted the
forced displacement of indigenous
peoples meant that they could not gather
food for themselves in their traditional
ways and they were coerced into buying
food from the market economy that was
set up by the colonists
at the same time white settlers
appropriated traditional indigenous
knowledge practices and land for their
own purposes
similarly after the american civil war
the enactment of no trespass and stock
laws prevented newly freed black and
african people from accessing the
commons they were often forced to go
back to work for white landowners rather
than being able to sustain themselves
through foraging and raising livestock
on the commons
and today food security issues are
widespread in the us
in 2020 according to the usda 10.5
percent of u.s households did not have
enough food due to lack of money and
other resources
foraging remains an essential practice
for some people to feed themselves
however the recent black lives matter
movement has emphasized the fact that
black bodies continue to be under more
threat than white bodies in the u.s the
ability to be outside safe and able to
forage is not a privilege that we all
share and my thesis research seeks to
understand the ways in which networked
foraging communities deal with issues of
power and access
second we are in a very difficult time
in which climate change is advancing
industrial pollution is widespread and
digital media platforms have exacerbated
the living conditions of people around
the world
the precarity lab led by lisa nakamura
at the university of michigan ann arbor
describes our current conditions as
techno precarious
techno precarity disproportionately
affects racial ethnic and sexual
minorities women indigenous peoples the
socio-economically poor
migrants and people in the global south
in this context networked foraging is an
important topic because it brings up
excuse me it brings up questions about
how network foraging practices and
cultures affect other humans and the
broader ecological community
so third
this topic raises important questions
around
the relationships between tech companies
and the people who use their products
and services
companies like meta and google have a
lot of power to influence the way that
we interact with each other and the
world around us
so it's worth exploring the ways in
which the design of algorithms and
interfaces may affect how we navigate
within the environment and the kinds of
relationships we develop
and finally i think this research opens
up exciting possibilities for
redesigning digital tools and platforms
to nurture more positive ecological
relationships
there are ways in which social media
platforms and digital apps can
facilitate stronger communication within
human communities as well as across
species
so the key question underlying much of
my research is
how do people use instagram and facebook
to learn about and practice networked
foraging and how do these practices
differentially value and affect bodies
so in other words how do people use
digital tools to learn how to forage and
communicate with others about their
foraging experiences and knowledge
and how does the way in which people use
digital technology benefit some people
and living beings more than others
i approached my research from a
particular perspective not just as a
student in comparative media studies at
mit but also as a white non-religious
cisgender woman
before coming to mit i worked as a ux
researcher in tech as well as an
academic researcher studying
environmental and social
responsibility and sustainability in the
private sector
so although i've long been interested in
the environment i didn't know much about
foraging or environmental science when i
started this research
and inspired by anna singh's book the
mushroom at the end of the world i went
on several foraging journeys in order to
get a sense of what network foraging is
like in practice for me
in my thesis i write about these
journeys as a way to more explicitly
acknowledge my own stakes in this
research project including the ethical
dilemmas i faced and the forms of
privilege that i experienced
and doing this research has helped me
recognize the ways in which i've been
socialized into
settler colonial white supremacist
heteronormative and capitalist systems
so for this project i use an approach to
thinking about media
developed by the american
media theorist and historian john durham
peters in his 2016 book the marvelous
clouds
according to peter's media are not just
devices like televisions or cell phones
but they can be understood more broadly
as
labeling environments or infrastructural
media that nurture many different life
forms including other media
this framework conceives of media as our
quote infrastructures of being the
habitats and materials through which we
act and are
end quote
peters revives aristotle's notion of
media as things in the middle by
developing this framework which builds
on the work of marcel mose harold innis
and friedrich hitler among other
scholars
so i use this infrastructural media
framework in order to address questions
about the relationships between bodies
land iphones and web apps in the context
of foraging
so if we can imagine a ship as a medium
that humans use to navigate the sea we
can also think of smartphones as media
that enable people to navigate the world
in particular ways
and as cherokee hawaiian and samoan
media theorist jason edward lewis
observes
designers and developers of media
technology choose what counts as
knowledge what sorts of operations we
can perform on that knowledge and how
that knowledge becomes manifest in the
world
the fact that they are often doing so
without being conscious or deliberative
about how they are reenacting a matrix
of fundamental assumptions about human
nature and human work in no way lessens
the impact of those decisions
for this research project i used a few
different qualitative research methods i
first completed a thematic analysis of
instagram posts and facebook foraging
group posts in order to get a sense of
the kinds of content network foragers
were sharing and talking about online
and the results of this analysis
informed the development of the
discussion guides that i used in
subsequent semi-structured interviews
so after that i conducted 60 to 90
minute interviews with nine people
there were three instagram users with
more than ten thousand followers and six
members of a local public facebook
foraging group
i selected a group of interviewees
across a range of identified genders
ages and levels of foraging experience
two of the people identified as black
with hispanic latinx or spanish ancestry
and seven identified as white
i used pseudonyms to allow my research
participants to feel more comfortable
reflecting on their experiences and
and feelings about the group-based
social dynamics they
were observing on facebook
and in addition i met up with two of my
interviewees to observe them foraging
outside in real time and finally i went
on my own solo foraging journeys as i
mentioned before to see what it was like
to use digital apps to learn about the
environment
so after collecting my interview and
participant observation data i went
through and coded the transcripts to
identify key themes in the way that
people were describing their experiences
and the processes they used to learn
about foraging
after writing up a first draft of my
thesis i shared with each of my
interviewees a summary of my analysis
along with the quotes that i'd selected
to include and i offered them an
opportunity to revise their quotes if
they wanted
and i also asked them for feedback on my
analysis or if they wanted to share any
additional thoughts and
i've heard back from most folks so far
and so far everyone has approved my
analysis and the quotes with a few minor
kind of cosmetic changes
the first set of findings relate to how
the people i interviewed oriented
themselves within their local
environments and began to learn how to
identify unfamiliar species
so my interview we've all described a
process of gathering various sources of
information primarily from blogs excuse
me websites like wikipedia and mobile
phone apps like google maps and seek by
inaturalist
across many different levels of
experience all of them described relying
on digital media to share and discuss
foraging content with others
one of my interviewees james described
how much of his learning process
happened online because it was often too
expensive to leave his home he said
when i was on facebook groups i didn't
have enough money to leave my house like
you can go outside or you go outside and
you can spend 100 just from blinking
your eyes so i'd be at home all the time
and i would just be on the internet
talking to people and posting pictures
and looking at pictures
and digital photographs seem to be the
primary medium through which people
shared information about the environment
within the facebook group there was a
codified practice for how to photograph
different kinds of species
and there was also an unspoken consensus
among my interviewees that a key first
skill to develop as a forager is to
learn how to identify a particular
species which involves naming discreet
living beings that make up the
environment
among my interviewees the linnaean
taxonomic system a legacy of western
imperialism and subtler colonialism
seemed to be the undisputed standard for
determining the identity of a particular
organism
one of my interviewees brynn described
their experience photographing species
they said i always take a picture of the
thing in its natural environment i get
the surrounding area to show what kind
of tree it's on or under and i get up
close shots of the thing itself if it's
a plant you know get leaves get stem get
berries get flowers whatever
my interview reads would then upload
these photos to facebook and others
would share their ideas on what the
species was and offered their own
opinions on what particular particular
species looked tasted smelled or felt
like
so the process of learning how to
identify a new species was very much an
embodied one people essentially had to
train their bodies to recognize new
species based on many different sensory
perceptions
in this context i adopt christina
graceny's concept of skilled vision as
an embodied skilled trained sense and a
useful one for thinking about the ways
in which foragers learn to identify new
species
building on moses concept of body
technique graseni proposes that skilled
vision involves a multi-sensory active
search for information from the
environment which can integrate
multi-sensory manipulations such as
touching cutting or tasting in the con
in the case of foraging
determining whose ideas and knowledge to
trust was an important part of the
learning process since not everyone
agreed on the facts um many interviewees
described determining whom they trusted
online based on whether the people had
well-developed facebook or other social
media profiles
whether they provided links to websites
to back up the claims and how much
western scientific knowledge they shared
in support of their claims
one of my interviewees who was a
foraging group moderator described how
he assessed the expertise of others
you kind of have to know names of people
you need to watch who's helping people
who's backing up their claims with
evidence and links to papers and
websites you know to confirm what
they're doing who are the people on
facebook a lot giving confident
identifications
for these people learning from digital
technologies and facebook foraging
experts is integral to the process of
developing skilled vision
the group-based interpretive lens
through which networked foragers learn
to perceive and make sense of the world
this process of orienting oneself and
learning to identify new species may be
constrained by the perspectives of
people who have the time and resources
to volunteer as experts within these
facebook groups
it was difficult to find leaders in the
facebook foraging group i studied or
even regular members who weren't white
and i wondered what alternative forms of
scientific knowledge it approaches to
foraging were not represented or
validated within these communities
so for example in her book braiding
sweetgrass originally published in 2013
robin wall kimmerer who is a professor
of environmental and forest biology and
member of the citizen potawatomi nation
writes of the honorable harvest a set of
unspoken unwritten indigenous principles
for foraging based on as she puts it
accountability to both the physical and
the metaphysical worlds
end quote
in her own foraging experience kimmer
describes using a kind of skilled vision
that is attuned to the needs and desires
of the species that she is harvesting
this type of skilled vision did not seem
to be taught within the facebook
community that i observed
the kind of skilled vision that i
observed seemed to be in particular a
specifically white way of seeing the
landscape that is produced through this
networked foraging space on facebook
as zoe todd writes citing broadcast 2011
a critique of whiteness is meant to draw
attention to the structural routinized
aspects of white public space and in
this spirit i hope that future research
explores the possibilities of
decentering whiteness within networked
forging communities like the one i
studied
the remaining findings that i'll share
i'll go through relatively quickly due
to time constraints
some of my additional findings relate to
how the people i interviewed decided how
and what to harvest and consume
before consuming anything my
interviewees described the process they
used to figure out whether something was
edible or toxic
some of the people i spoke with said
that they were discouraged from asking
questions about toxicity before learning
on a more intellectual level about the
species in question
an emphasis on learning that precludes
consumption suggests a denial of the
desiring hungering body and a value
sorry valuing of the kind of
disinterested intellectual brain
over carnal relations vital needs and
many ways of learning about and knowing
other species
it seemed that people who practice
foraging for their daily food needs may
not feel totally comfortable
participating in this kind of a facebook
group
and after learning how to prepare
foraged items that were deemed to be
non-toxic
my interviewees described the experience
of eating new foods as forming new
relationships
one person said that after learning how
to eat the fruit from a ginkgo tree they
felt that they in the tree were
essentially one in the same
this kind of sentiment suggested the
possibilities that exist for foraging to
be a way of coming to recognize the
personhood and agency of other species
many of my interviewees seemed to be
uncomfortable talking online about the
ethics of harvesting and consuming what
they had foraged
there was a phenomenon called picture
shaming in which people would according
to my interviewees shame others for
harvesting a species that was considered
endangered or for harvesting too much of
something or using harvested items in a
way deemed questionable
those who were identified as pick
shamers were often quickly blocked from
the facebook group
it seemed that the group didn't know how
to deal with difficult conversations
around ethics and morality
at the same time the digital apps that
my interviewees were using often did not
offer clear advice on how to harvest
something without potentially harming
the environment or how to harvest a
species in a way that promotes the
flourishing of its broader population
the third set of findings relate to how
the people i interviewed decided what to
record online about their foraging
experiences
perhaps not surprisingly the people i
interviewed described posting images and
experiences that they thought would get
the biggest amount of likes or other
forms of digital engagement
as a result one person described posting
images of abundance like a large number
of ripe berries rather than images of
less visually striking plants
on instagram images of the environment
may be biased in favor of the
spectacular
a couple of my interviewees described
holding back on what they shared of
themselves to their audiences for
example one of my interviewees who had
over 20 000 followers described getting
negative feedback from followers after
posting content about issues of
homelessness where he lives
his followers seem to want him to post
only about foraging and not about
politics suggesting that foraging is
somehow apolitical divorced from human
affairs and issues of land and property
ownership
on the other hand others talked about
posting on deliberately messy subjects
like mistakes they had made or they post
pictures that they thought were ugly
they felt this was a way of getting rid
of followers who weren't genuinely
interested in them as whole people
and finally some people talked about
posting online based on their
perceptions of how facebook and
instagram's algorithms worked for
example they would post videos more
frequently if they felt that instagram's
feed was prioritizing video content at
that moment in time
these findings demonstrate the ways in
which the design of social media
platforms and perceptions of the design
of social media
platforms influence the types of digital
content that networked foreigners
publish online
so just to quickly summarize my research
through interviews with instagram and
facebook users as well as participant
observation i found that networked
forging communities may privilege
whiteness and individualism commodify
nature and deny other forms of knowledge
and ways of knowing other forms of life
i also found that digital media used by
network foragers often fails to account
for the needs and experiences of more
than human forms of life this research
study uses data from a very small
population just six members of one
facebook foraging group and three
instagram users
other studies may investigate networked
foraging practices within a larger
population and also across other social
media platforms
some questions that could be interesting
to explore include
how might network foraging communities
design new digital tools that decenter
white forms of knowledge and capitalist
values
in what ways might digital apps be
redesigned to better account for the
needs and experiences of other forms of
life
and how are people in countries other
than the us using social media and
digital technologies to forage in what
ways might the cultures of networked
foraging communities vary across
geographic areas
um so i just want to thank my thesis
committee jim laura and darren for their
generous support and guidance throughout
this project many thanks also to
the cmsw faculty and staff to my cohort
and the cohort from the year before
to my wonderful family and friends and
to the people who spent their time
talking with me and going on forays
thank you very much for listening and
i'd be happy to answer any questions or
share feedback you may have
good
where someone said something on facebook
when they kicked them out because they
didn't know how to handle them
yeah i you know in it
yeah yeah sure the question from tomas
was around like who
who are the moderators of these facebook
foraging groups and how do they sort of
um
manage these decisions around like
blocking people or not blocking people
based on what they say
um
i talked with one moderator um and
this person
this person
seemed to kind of totally dismiss the
notion that
shaming people was um
acceptable and that there were
it just seemed like there were no clear
methods for
addressing these kinds of conflicts that
come up and
and like mediating conversation so the
the first response for that person that
i spoke with was basically just to
remove
um
remove the person from the group um
another person i spoke with who wasn't a
moderator but was
like seen as an expert within the
community talked about
removing people from the group
automatically as being
a very standard practice and not one
really to question um
almost like fake news in a way like it
struck me as strange that
there was no kind of distinction between
um
science and ethics because i think that
is really a meaningful distinction to
make within this kind of group and
um and people just said like whatever
like if someone was like
you shouldn't harvest a mushroom in that
way like that's not good um or you
shouldn't harvest that many mushrooms or
something
um there there can be clear kind of
environmental reasons for making those
claims as well as ethical reasons for
making those claims and
it just seemed like
yeah for some reason the moderators
often or
usually did not
recognize that differentiation so i
think it'd be definitely worth exploring
more
talking with more moderators and getting
a sense of how they work together behind
the scenes and
also how they think individually about
those kinds of issues
yes heather um i was interested in my
view one of your
opening promises about drawing on uh
and her uh needs to be networked
and i was thinking about her as you were
referring to community
um and foraging
and you know started at kentucky's uh
notion of community is very based in
like physical presence people together
communities whereas social uh media and
other kinds of platforms are
uh for communication they're more like
tools yeah
community experiences
and
any community they have is um virtual or
like not whatever you want
not about physical presence and i'm just
curious about if i understand it
correctly if you have thoughts on that
yeah that's a great question um so
heather was asking about
um
my use of the term networked and the
kinds of communities that form around
foraging online relative to what zainab
um tufaki observed in her own sort of
research on networked protest movements
which were much more about kind of
physical presence um and i think i was i
was actually anticipating before
starting this project that the facebook
groups would be more sites for
organizing meetups and less about like
doing foraging solo together alone
together as sherry trickle might say um
so yeah it's it was interesting hearing
about
the
incredible role that digital
technologies play in this learning
process and how how people like
really seem to think it's it's
reasonable and useful to
translate sensory experiences um from
the physical world into like words on a
facebook group um
so like i mean for example the matsutake
mushroom as anna singh explores it
smells very different to different
people like some people describe it as
like heavenly they pay large sums of
money for it other people think it
doesn't smell very good at all they
would rather avoid it entirely it was
just interesting to me that there was no
recognition of the subjectivities of
sensory perceptions and um so i wondered
kind of how that might affect people's
ways of identifying certain species and
understanding them
um and yeah i guess i guess i want to
point out though that um
the groups were occasionally used as um
places to kind of advertise in a light
way like hey i'm going on a foraging
walk next weekend if anyone wants to
meet up with me totally can so it did
seem like people did meet up in person
on occasion but it wasn't the kind of
default way of
gathering together
tia
so i asked this question
you live in the city
yeah i think
let me know if i'm misinterpreting it
but um the question from tl was like
how how do i think about um the role of
soil or the role of like
the
kind of monolithic landscape in in
between
the people who are doing the foraging
and the things that are being foraged
yeah um
so
the thing about the group that i studied
was that it was a local group but
distributed pretty broadly um within a
region so
what one person experienced in one
community
may not be relevant to another person in
the same group
so i didn't notice really many
conversations at all talking about
like local heavy metal presence within
soils or other environmental
contaminants
but people did talk about like they had
kind of certain heuristics for
um staying away from places that may be
more toxic than others like staying away
from roadways or walking paths where
dogs might pee on something um
but then like
i think i listened to a podcast by
alexis nicole nelson who talks about how
like pretty much everything has been
peed on by something at some point you
know
um and and alexis nicole nelson actually
um talked in more detail about
reading the landscape
by
understanding potentially the
soil erosion sort of status of the
particular area that you're in so that
if you can tell that erosion is
potentially a problem there then you
wouldn't clear away like brush or um you
might find somewhere that
uh
is more exposed maybe to the wind and
doesn't have that much problem what does
it doesn't seem to be dealing with that
issue
um so
yeah it just seemed like maybe the more
complex
observations about
ecosystems and contaminants were
happening um
were happening kind of in these kind of
deeper conversations on podcasts or um
from the accounts of social media i i
don't want to use the word influencers
because a lot of them reject that term
but people like alexis nicole nelson who
um has this really strong kind of broad
platform that is really
um aware of the history of foraging and
aware of the power dynamics and
ecological kind of dynamics i thought
that was like really the most
educational
place to to look for that kind of
information
um
and then i think
there was also someone i interviewed who
talked about
really getting to know the land they
were foraging on um they said they spent
like i want to say a year or something
studying the local milkweed population
before
touching it like they just wanted to see
what other kinds of creatures interacted
with that species and
how they interacted with it and whether
the milkweed population was strong
enough to really be foraged and they
really took their time going back like
again and again to see how it evolved
over time
and i think having that kind of
rooted relationship with um an area of
land
is super important for understanding the
kind of
broader issues that the land is facing
or um or or just observing kind of like
visual cues that might let you know that
maybe something's different here than
you expected it to be
um
and and with other people it seemed like
foraging was more of a form of
entertainment but
didn't require so much attention to
detail in time and so
that's where i would worry that maybe
people aren't aware so much of
the presence of certain environmental
toxicants um from industrial pollution
that would affect the sort of eating
quality of whatever they're consuming
um
did that answer your question
thanks this is uh
oh thank you jen that's a great question
so what is the future of network
foraging is it expanding contracting in
a steady state
um
i
i'm not sure how to answer that question
because
um
i think
foraging exists in different ways in
different parts of the world for
different reasons and
um
i've studied one small group um and
i'm not sure
i'm not sure how to draw kind of broader
projections or
inferences about like how it might
unfold over time but
it does seem to me that um
with the changes brought about by
climate change as well as industrial
pollution and mass migrations
displacements
i think that it's important for people
to
really pay attention to the land around
them and
and
get a better sense of
the communities that they're a part of
and how they can help heal their own
communities
not just through things like
volunteering to like do restoration
projects or things like that but also
the people i spoke with talked about
using their bodies as tools of
environmental management um so they
would eat invasive species or
species they considered to be
potentially harmful to the vision of the
the landscape that they imagined um
so i think i think being able to talk
about
locally kind of what our vision is for
the future and how we can work together
with plants with mushrooms you know if
you will um
how to kind of bring about
more reciprocal relationships more
symbiotic relationships
ones that sort of remind us that we
depend on land and that land
is part of our identity i think that's
super important and i hope that um
that it continues to be
an interesting source of conversation
for people and also that people continue
to learn about the history of foraging
and the political implications of
foraging
thank you so much